اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من يخشى على مستقبل
النظام السياسي لا يرفع الحصانه عن النائب
المنتخب النواب يمثلون ضمير الشعب وحصانته
هي تاكيد للاراده الشعبيه التي اختارتهم
للعمل تحت قبه البرلمان بمثل هذه المواقف
والشعارات التي تشير لرفع الحصانه عن خمسه
نواب مقربين من دحلان هتف المشاركون في
مظاهره في غزه والواضح ان الصراع بين جناح
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس القائد العام
لحركه فتح وتيار القيادي المفصول منها
محمد دحلان لا كاد يتوقف الا ليتجدد بزخم
اكبر واراده اقوى على المضي في طريق
المواجهه من غزه ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
وائل الدحدوح وائل بدايه ما الجديد الذي
حملته هذه المظاهرات
الجديد هي انها الفعاليه الاولى ربما التي
اخذت طابعا جماهيريا لانصار القائد
المفصول من حركه فتح محمد حلان والتي تاتي
عقب المؤتمر السابع لحركه فتح الذي عقد في
مدينه رام الله في ال9 وال من الشهر
الماضي وهي ايضا الفعاليه الاولى بعد يوم
واحد فقط من جلسه للمجلس التشريعي ضمت
نواب الكتله البرلمانيه لحركه حماس وسبعه
او
16 من نواب حركه فتح التقوا تحت قبه
البرلمان وهو الامر الذي يشير ان هذه
الفعاليه والتظاهر يمكن ان تدشن مرحله
جديده من من الخلافات داخل البيت الفتحاوي
ان لم يصار الى لملمه وحل هذه
الخلافات هنا في ساحه برلمان الشعب
الفلسطيني المنتخب هو رساله ينبغي ان
يلتقطها الجميع هي رساله وجهها انصار
القيادي المفصول من حركه فتح محمد دحلان
الى قياده الحركه وتحديد
الى رئيسها الرئيس محمود عباس رساله
انطلقت من امام مقر المجلس التشريعي
بمدينه غزه وحملت في طياتها مدلولات كثيره
فهي اولى التداعيات التي اخذت طابعا
جماهيريا بعد المؤتمر السابع الذي عقد في
ال9 والعشرين من الشهر الماضي في رام الله
وكان ابرز عناوينه ترتيب البيت
الفتحاوي يبدو انه يحتاج الى كثير من
التدقيق في ظل هذه التطورات فهذه التظاهر
قد تشير الى مرحله اخرى من الخلافات داخل
حركه فتح قد تقابلها اجراءات صارمه من
قياده الحركه ضد من تصفهم
بالمتجمد وامه الخلافات عوضا عن حلها
واحتوائها فشكرا على استجابتكم وحضوركم
هذه الجلسه الطارئه والتي تعد جلسه هامه
من اجل الدفاع عن حصانه النواب التظاهر
جاءت ايضا بعد يوم واحد من جلسه للمجلس
التشريعي في غزه ضمت نواب كتله حماس
البرلمانيه بمشاركه وموافقه 16 نائبا من
حركه فتح وخصصت لرفض اجراءات الرئيس
الفلسطيني برفع الحصانه البرلمانيه عن
خمسه من نواب فتح من بينهم محمد دحلان وهو
ما رفضته ايضا الفصائل الفلسطينيه
الرئيسيه باعتبار ان ذلك من اختصاص المجلس
التشريعي الذي انتخبه الشعب نحن
نعلن افتتاح اعمال مؤتمرنا
السابع واللي مش عاجبه يصفر تلويح الرئيس
الفلسطيني لدى اعلانه افتتاح اعمال مؤتمر
حركه فتح السابع اعتبر حينها موجها الى
اطراف عربيه تدعم دحلا لكنه اتبع برفع
الحصانه البرلمانيه عن خمسه من نواب
الحركه
وبمحافظة الفلسطيني مصمم على المضي قدما
نحو الاطاحه بكل من يوصفون
بالمتجمد
يجعل المرحله المقبله داخل حركه فتح
مفتوحه على كل
الاحتمالات شكرا جزيلا وائل الدحدوح مراسل
الجزيره في غزه وتعمق اكثر في هذا الملف
ينضم الينا من رام الله الكاتب والصحفي
محمد هواش و من غزه استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بجامعه الازهر الدكتور عماد محسن وابدا بك
دكتور عماد من غزه ما الرساله التي تقراها
في وجود هذه المظاهره بهذا الحجم في قطاع
غزه وانعقاد المجلس التشريع بمشاركه حركه
حماس وحركه فتح ايضا في قطاع غزه ما
الرساله
ولمن الرساله من جماهير غزيه اعلنت تمسكها
بالاراده الشعبيه المرتبطه بانتخاب النواب
من جهه وهي رساله بتقديرهم للجهه التي
مارست سطوا مسلحا على النظام السياسي
الفلسطيني عندما قهرت بالقوه نوابا
منتخبين ومنعتهم من تفعيل مجلسهم التشريع
على مدى سنوات على الاقل بعد الاتفاق في
الشاطئ في العام 2014 واصبح هناك حكومه
توافق وطني وبالتالي كان ينبغي على الهيئه
التشريعيه ان تنعقد هذه رساله من هذه
الجماهير للجهه التي تستقوي بقضاء مسيس
على نواب انتخبهم الشعب وتنكرت هذهه القوه
لاراده الناخبين والاراده الشعبيه التي
جاءت به وقبل كل ذلك
وبعده السلطه التنفيذيه والرئيس محمود
عباس والفريق الذي يسانده في هذا التمزيق
على اسا هل نهم في هذه القضيه في هذه
القطه تح هل نفهم في هذه النقطه تحديدا ان
حركه حماس
والمجموعه التي ربما تكون تابعه لمحمد
دحلان يعني متوافقون حول هذه
النقطه المساله ليست مساله مجموعه تابعه
لمحمد دحلان وحركه حماس بقدر ما انه
الجميع يعني المجموعه التي من ضمنها
النائب محمد دحلان ارسلت رساله للقياده
السياسيه قبل بضعه اشهر طالبت بتفعيل
الهيئه التشريعيه المجلس التشريعي حتى
يقوم النائب
بالوظيفه ال ال المرهون عملوا بهما الاولى
سن التشريعات والقوانين من جهه والمساله
الثانيه مسائله السلطه التنفيذيه عن
اجراءاتها ال الغاضبون الذين خرجوا اليوم
في غزه في النهايه هم مجموعات كبيره من
الشباب الغزي الاف منهم خرجت تواجه ثالوث
احبطه على مدى 12 ع سنه من جهه الاحت
الاحتلال وحصاره الجائر على قطاع غزه ومن
جهه ثانيه الانقسام البغيض الذي عمق الام
واوجاع الفلسطينيين ومن جهه ثالثه التهميش
المقصود والمتعمد الذي تمارسه السلطه
الفلسطينيه بحق هؤلاء الشبان الذين
يواجهون الفقر والبطاله من جهه وانسداد
الافق الاقتصادي والسياسي والاجتماعي من
جهه اخرى طيب نتوجه ايضا الى ضيفنا من رام
الله السيد محمد هواش برايك هذه التجاذبات
يعني الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس اتهم من
قبل اعضاء في فتح ومن قبل سياسيين ومحللين
وقانونيين فلسطينيين بانه تجاوز القانون
الاساسي بحرمان النواب من الحصانه الى اين
يمكن ان يتجه الى اي مدى يمكن ان يتجه هذا
الخلاف بين دحلان والرئيس
عباس يعني اولا هذه مواضيع وقضايا متعدده
ما يطرح ما سمعته من ضيفك الكريم وفي
التقرير ايضا وما تشرفت به الان هي مواضيع
مختلفه
ومتنوعه قضايا تتعلق بصلاحيات الرئيس
قضايا تتعلق بصلاحيات المجلس التشريعي
وقضايا اخرى خلافيه داخل حركه فتح وهي
حركه سياسيه كبيره وواسعه وكل الحركات
الجماهيريه الواسعه يعني تتعرض لخلافات
وتتعرض لمشكلات وتجاوزها تجاوز زتها حركه
فتح بصوره رئيسيه وجوهر من خلال عقد مؤتمر
اي باجراء ديمقراطي وليس باجراء اخر اما
فيما يتعلق يعني بكل قضيه على حده قضيه
مجلس التشريع الفلسطيني لم تعقد مج جلسه
للمجلس التشريع المجلس التشريعي الفلسطيني
معطل بسبب الانقسام السياسي ويتحمل كل
الاطراف الفلسطينيين مسؤوليه تعطيل المجلس
التشريعي واليوم يعني عندما تعق قد جلسات
او لقاءات لبعض اعضاء المجلس التشريعي
لمناقشه فكره
يعني صلاحيه او عدم صلاحيه الرئيس وهو
رئيس كل السلطات الفلسطينيه ورئيس اي سلطه
يتم تجميدها او او تتوقف عن العمل يقوم
الرئيس بصوره او باخرى باصدار قرارات
ومراسيم بدل السلطه
التشريعيه النواب الخمسه الذين رفعت
الحصانه عنهم لم يفصلوا من المجلس التشريع
ولم يتخذ بحقهم اجراء قانوني يتعلق بعضوهم
في المجلس التشريعي ولكن معرضين لتساؤل من
القضاء وبالتالي لا يمكن للقضاء ان يقوم
بمسائل هؤلاء الذين يعني لديهم
شبهات كما كما قيل بفساد وباختلاف وب
يعني تجاوزات وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يمثلوا
امام القضاء ولديهم حصانه الحصانه يرفعها
المجلس التشريعي اذا كان المجلس التشريعي
يقوم باعماله واذا تعطل المجلس التشريعي
الرئيس يقوم باعم يقوم بدل المجلس
التشريعي برفع الحصانه لمقاضاته وليس ل
يعني محاسبتهم او قطع رؤوسهم او او فصل او
فصل هؤلاء من البرلمان هذا اجراء قانوني
ويمكن للقانونيين ان يختلفوا او يتفقوا
على صحه هذا الاجراء و عدم هذا الاجراء
طيب اما فيما يتعلق بجموع دح اعتقد ان
المؤتمر الى اي مدى سيمضي الرئيس
الفلسطيني في هذا الاتجاه وهو اتجاه
تصعيدي مع فريق من داخل حركه
فتح لم افهم السؤال الى اي مدى سيتجه
الرئيس عباس في هذا المسار التصعيدي مع
مجموعه دحلان ضمن حركه
فتح اولا الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس لم
يصعد ضد دحلان او ضد اي فريق ولا يوجد
فريق الرئيس هو رئيس السلطه الفلس
فلسطينيه ورئيس منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
ورئيس حركه فتح ولا يوجد داخل حركه فتح
اتجاهات و
يعني مشكلات و والى ما هنالك هناك افراد
لديهم مشكلات مع حركه فتح وهذا حق لهم ان
يعبروا عن ارائهم ويختلف مع الحركه
والحركه هي الوحيده الكفيله يعني بالتعامل
مع هذه المشكلات انا لا افهم يعني الحكمه
من فصل محمد دحلان و وغير محمد دحلان ولكن
يعني مرت حركه فتح بمشكلات اعمق بكثير من
هذه المشكله ومرت بخلافات اعمق بكثير من
الخلاف مع شخص مثل محمد دحلان مثل صبر
البنا مثل
مجموعه مجموعه فتح الانتفاضه وكان وكانت
تضم ثلاثه اعضاء في اللجنه المركزيه وعدد
كبير من اعضاء المجلس السي لحركه فتح معظم
وخيره ضباط حركه فتح انشقوا ط خلافات
طبيعيه تحدث في كل الحرق عن الحركه وا
ومشت نعم نعم ولكن ولكن هناك يعني كانت
هناك خلافات سياسيه مع العراق كانت خلافات
سياسيه مع سوريا اليوم لا نفهم ما هو
الخلاف ما هو البرنامج السياسي الذي لد
لدى دحلان وما يسمى بمجموعه دحلان الذي
يختلف عن البرنامج السياسي للسلطه ال
اسمحلي نتوجه بهذا السؤال الى ضيفنا من
غزه السيد عماد محسن يعني ما الخلاف فعلا
السياسي هل هنالك مشروع مختلف لمحمد دحلان
عن مشروع الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس حتى
يصل الخلاف الى هذا هذه الدرجه م ويصل الى
ساحات القضاء واتهامات متبادله بالقتل
والاغتيال والاختلاس
والفساد ليس محمد دحلان هو الذي يعني قاد
الامور بهذه الوجهه البائسه التي يعاني
منها الكل الفتحاوي بالمناسبه بس يعني هو
تعقيب صغير على ما تفضل به ضيفك الكريم
يعني لا ي مجال على الاطلاق لمحمد دحلان
الذي يختلف عن المشروع السياسي لمحمود
عباس حتى نرى كل هذه الخلافه ساتي على هذه
الجزئيه
من اظن بانه لا يجوز ولا ينبغي يعني بحكم
دلاله المنطق والجغرافيا والتاريخ ان نشبه
ما يحدث وما حدث مع محمد دحلان بما حدث و
يعني في الماضي مع صبري المنا ومجموعه ابو
موسى وغيرهم هؤلاء انشقوا عن فتح حملوا
السلاح في مواجهتها وقتلوا رجالها محمد
دحلان فقط كل ما يتعلق به هو مجموعه من
النميمه
بالمعنى الشعبي للكلمه وسمعنا اكثر من تيل
م لمسؤولين كبار تولوا التحقيق قض به
اعلنوا اكدوا ليس مشروع الرجلين هو
مشروع مشروع المفاوضات المستمره مع
اسرائيل هل هنالك شيء
مختلف لا محمد دحلان لديه وجهه نظر في
اطار البرنامج السياسي الذي اقرته فتح على
الدوام منذ العام
1989 مبادره السلام الفلسطين صينيه التي
اعلنها الرئيس الراحل ياسى عرفات امام
الامم المتحده في جنيف عندما ال ان الوجهه
هي انسحاب اسرائيل من اراض من الاراضي
التي احتلتها في العام 1967 غير منقوصه
شبر واحد وعاصمتها القدس وحل عادي لقضيه
اللاجئين على اساس القرار الاممي 194 ال
المساله هنا فقط في جزئيتين الجزئيه
الاولى تعاون امني مقدس بدون ثمن سياسي
مرفوض بال القطع والمساله الثانيه انه ان
المقاومه الذكيه وحدها لا تكفي لمواجهه
الاحتلال وانما فتح المجال امام كل يعني
ادوات الشعب الفلسطيني الابداعيه ان
تستخدم في مواجهه المحتل يعني لا شيء اكثر
من ذلك على بالاضافه بطبيعه الحال الى شيء
من المسلكيات السياسيه والاداريه التي
يمكن معالجتها يعني بحوار معمق في الاطار
الحرى الله اذا لا خلاف في المشروع
السياسي الخلاف يبدو شخصي على قياده
الحركه كيف سيؤثر ذلك على حركه
فتح
اي يعني الخلاف
الخلاف ليس شخصيا تماما ولكن ولكن هناك
يعني اجتهادات مختلفه وهناك تحالفات
مختلفه وهناك محاولات الاستقواء بقوى
عربيه صديقه للشعب الفلسطيني ووقف الى
جانب الشعب الفلسطيني على فترات طويله
وتختلف مع الشعب وتختلف مع قياده الشعب
الفلسطيني في بعض التكتيكات وبعض المواقف
السياسيه واعتقد بان يعني السيد محمد
دحلان يستقوي بهذه الخلافات ويكبر ويضخم
هذه الخلافات مع السلطه الفلسطينيه ويحاول
ويحاول ان يعتق يسوق يسوق فكره انه يستطيع
ان يقود الشعب الفلسطيني بطريقه افضل من
قياده الرئيس محمود عباس هذه
مساله تقرر قها حركه فتح وتقرر منظمه
التحرير وتقرر يعني الهيئات الشعبيه
الفلسطينيه والانتخابات و وكل الشعب
الفلسطيني يشارك في هذا الموضوع ليس محمد
دحلان وليس اي شخص اخر السيد محمد هواش
الكاتب الصحفي من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك
واشكر ضيفي من غزه السيد عماد محسن استاذ
العلوم السياسيه بجامعه الازهر بغزه شكرا
جزيلا السودان بجد المحتدم بشان حريه
الصحافه والحريات العامه بصوره اشمل هو
مضوع ملفنا الثالث مع محمود مراد